right and honestly i and i will admit
that i haven't done enough
research into regulation specifically i
am
not opposed however to something like
you talked about section 230 reform
yeah i would be okay with that yeah i
would be okay with
with with talking about that but i think
my problem is is when people
like trump say that we need to get rid
of section 230 protections when it's
like
they just don't know what the heck
they're talking yeah he's stringing
himself up with that
that would be the end of all of these
conservatives if section 230 was gone
like we wouldn't be able to have this
conversation live right now
well we would because i'm verified on
youtube ah
okay and that's the way it works the
elites are allowed and i think that's
what's coming right do you guys see that
pornhub
just nuked all unverified content luke's
not nodding because he probably
discovered it
like manually how dare you
exactly pornography is a sin and it's
rotting away
the ute of this nation and destroying
their brains
and there's a strong argument that a
real opinion there's yeah i mean there's
a strong argument
to make against pornography and the
effects especially on young children
that it's having that is rotting their
brains away literally
i really i don't think i think there's
good porn like one out of every 30
is good this is personal this is
anecdotal but where they actually like
each other like okay okay we're not
talking about porn we're talking about
let's talk about how you can't
get a partisan a non-partisan no no no
no no listen we're talking about how
pornhub
nuked all unverified we're talking about
bureaucracy yes
no we're talking about censorship all
unverified content was removed
youtube did this thing we started
pulling verification badges from
channels
i think youtube is listen it's a long
it's a long known and silicon valley
thing that you can't change the rules
overnight
when the famous story that i've told
many many times is that
ebay used to be yellow you probably
never heard the story i'll tell you
so the original ebay website was yellow
one day they said
yellow is like off-putting we're like
we're gonna make the we're gonna make a
white background yeah
the next day everybody revolted they
were like the site's awful we hate it
what happened and they were getting
endless complaints from people
so they immediately changed it back okay
okay yellow then the next day
and for every day then on they slowly
incremented one tiny bit towards white
until a year later the website was white
no one cared because you noticed
exactly no one noticed so what's
happening now i think is you see pornhub
does this
and everyone's like well it's pornhub
whatever that makes sense right because
they were like there were crazy
accusations about you know
trafficking and underage girls that i
always i did always that's kind of weird
that like anybody could upload stuff to
like to pornhub and i'm like
how do they verify the ages of these
people you know yeah i
used to think that same kind of stuff
like you you probably got to verify that
kind of stuff
right especially if it could be
trafficking you need to make sure
there's you know these people are
consenting this stuff
but then i just think what's going to
happen with youtube
they did the the the verification
removal wave where all these channels
got their badges removed actually if i
could just
really quickly cut in because i remember
that happening because i was actually
one of the creators that got contacted
by youtube and i was told that
that my creator badge was gonna be taken
um
and i was like pissed af about it
obviously uh and then youtube quickly
said they weren't going to do that yeah
they because there was an outros
there was a revolt right and that's the
point right how was that censorship
though
well censorship is just like you know
hiding information
yeah but like taking the checks away
wasn't that's not censorship so it's
it's frogs in a pot right
now uh since since then they've been
pulling people from the partner program
instead of doing a wave of removing
badges they said okay we got to do it
one by one
individually to random people in
different communities so that no one
gets angry and starts a news cycle about
it
since then they've purged tons of
channels this year alone youtube said in
their own statement 8 000 channels have
been deleted
yeah so that's how they slowly start
getting rid of them without causing an
uproar
the reason i bring this up is in term
you know in the in the texting 230
conversation
yeah what i think is going to happen is
eventually youtube's going to be like
you have to be verified to produce on
youtube so that's why i said we'll
probably be fine because i am a verified
youtube channel they never threaten to
take my badges away
they you know i have direct contact with
people at google they tell me like when
there's rule changes i can call them and
they clarify and then you know
they they they like me in that regard
because i'm rather mild toast i suppose
well the boiling the frog analogy is
good because not a lot of people know
this but scott adams and jeff burwick
just had their channels totally taken
off
and just like you you said same thing
kind of happened to me but then they got
rid of my partner program later on and
i'm like wait
what's going on here and another
important thing that youtube announced
is that
they also will start putting
advertisements on
channels that are not in their partner
program anymore so they could put
ads on mine and i'm getting comments
saying hey there was an ad i'm happy i
got you know i was able to watch it for
you luke and i'm like
i'm not in the partner program anymore
and that just happened a couple days ago
are you verified
like a check mark i used to be verified
i i believe they took it away as well
with the partnership program yeah
so so i think i think one i think what's
going to happen next
is they're probably not going to say
anything they don't have to but
channels that don't have verification
probably already
are de-ranked in the algorithm yeah i
i can't speak for for i know i can't
speak from anecdotes but
god my channel is doing horrible right
now and i'm verified
so but that's because you like that's
because i left the right right well yeah
if you build an audience up where you
say something like you know backflips
are the best
and then all the backflip fans are going
yeah and then you change i was wrong
front flips are better they're going to
be like boom
and that's exactly what's happening to
me now is that yeah but if you know
start purging my audience of uh yup
farther right people unfortunately have
you thought about making a new channel
no because um uh no
it's it's challenging enough right now
to try to manage the one
um and it's just like like when i
when i announced that i was leaving the
right having built you know a
conservative audience i knew
that was going to be extremely
controversial and i knew that it was
going to be
pretty detrimental uh to my career for
the time being also as far as like view
counts and everything goes
um which is one of the reasons why i get
really frustrated when
people call me a grifter they say that i
just
ditched the right and joined the left
for the money or whatever and i'm like
i lost like 50 000 subs so far for
acknowledging that i'm no longer that i
no longer really align with the right i
think the hardest thing would probably
probably be to just choose to be wrong
you know
yeah it's it was hard to i'm kidding oh
really
i was making us no no i'm sorry i
thought you meant choosing to
acknowledge that you were wrong no
no well i guess that's a good point
because i did do that
by the way what did you what did you
take start to take issue with that you
used to believe
uh well i started well okay i started
taking issues just with the
right wing kind of in general first
which and i
i know that you know conservatives
they're very broad i'm not
putting i'm not trying to prescribe this
on all conservatives by any means but
my experience anyway i felt like
especially the further right you went
uh tradition took precedent and so it
was tradition
over really anything else even if that
was at the expense of other people's
rights
so i have a total problem with people
who although maybe not conservative
would be
far right uh having those people being
against gay marriage because it's not
traditional trump's four gay marriage
and he was pro-gay marriage before he
even
uh ran for before he ran and then he was
the he's the first president to be
pro-gay marriage before becoming
president
yeah so like he entered office he had a
famous photo where he's unfurling the
lgbt flag but that's not like he's but
that's the promise that's all he's done
he's done
he's been very detrimental for the lgbt
community well but maybe the gbt
community but i think
there's a lot of uh lesbians that are
actually very very much in support of
him he actually has a really large base
of gay men too
interesting peter thiel spoke at the rnc
and that was the first time a gay man
spoke at the rnc
more importantly trump gave a speech to
the rnc and got the republicans to clap
and cheer for the
for the lgbt community that was i mean
you know that may just be
clapping it's not really policy it's not
virtue signaling honestly because what
trump's doing is he's signaling to this
virtue that he's pro-lgbt but yet
now that he's been in government they
tried to uh the trump trump
administration asked the supreme court
if they could stop gay people from
adopting despite there being
repeated longitudinal studies which show
that
kids raised by gay parents do not fare
worse than their
um straight couple counterparts did he
ask or did he do it
well he wanted to do it so a lot do we
know that for sure is that source yeah
yeah you can look it up trump went to
i believe it was donald trump went to
the supreme court if you want to look
that up
um again i don't know all the details
off the top of my head so i'd love to
have more info right here but
was there a wait wait i think are you
referring to
when he said adoption agency should be
able to reject gay couples
how long ago was that so this is june
4th of this year
i thought it was more recent than that i
thought he was talking about a time
specifically where he wanted to
taxpayer-funded organization should be
able to refuse to work with same-sex
couples and others
whom the group considers to be in
violation of its religious beliefs
yes i'm not saying i agree with it i'm
just here's the specifics i think that
that would still kind of fall in line
with
violation of lgbt rights especially when
you talk about like
there are a bunch of kids in our foster
care system right now there and
and gay couples obviously are far more
likely to adopt because they can't have
children so i'm gonna do surrogates or
you know
well yeah you can do surrogates but also
there's a lot of kids that need homes
that need loving parents and
i i'm i have two children uh i'm a dad
and i'm married and i
i am a strong proponent of the nuclear
family actually that this is one of my
most conservative traditional viewpoints
so you're pretty anti-black lives matter
then no i know i know where you're going
with that though
what do you mean like one of their core
tenants is disrupting the nuclear family
i don't know if that's one of their core
types
it's on their web it was on their
website it's on the right there until
they pulled it out exactly
because of backlash but the website i
don't i don't agree well i'm not saying
like an individual who's cheering what
i'm saying like the organization itself
yeah
i don't like the nuclear family and i
don't like blm organization
but what i was saying is so i was right
well i like blm the movement but not the
organization well i was referring to the
organization so you agree
sir sure yeah um but yeah no i'm a big
proponent of the nuclear family but what
i always say is that the nuclear family
is just two parents
raising children it doesn't have to be a
straight couple raising the parents so
raising the kids so science actually
agrees with you on that one yeah the
they
they haven't been able to make a
determination if it's male and female or
just two parents
and i think like simply put
if we can get kids who are in orphanages
or you know who need to be adopted
to any loving family like that's
preferable to having a homeless kid
who's living in the system that's
terrible
right so i you know but but yeah there
was a report that came out where that
said like
the science so far that we've done can't
determine between male and you know
traditional like parents of like a male
men and a woman or
a you know same-sex couple right and
that the children are benefited equally
as far as we can tell
so far right so far exactly and and i
know that yeah
i don't know if it's the same study or
another one but i've looked at ones too
that showed that they
usually actually when children of gay
parents um
fare worse it's because of like social
stigma because of the gay parents
uh not so much like because anything to
do with the gay people necessarily
but yeah i mean that that's one instance
i guess of donald trump um
expressing some anti-lgbt sentiments
just one of them
i i don't think that trump is like this
malicious anti-gay
president um but i also think that he's
a bit virtue signaling when it comes to
that
trump we're just saying a lot yeah yeah
like tweeting repeal section 230
uh it's a really really bad idea but
he's trying to let conservatives know
like i'm fighting for you and it's kind
of like
but you're giving them what they want
when you say that like right
these democrats would are are like no
wait trump don't
because they want it to happen they want
230 gone said he wanted to imprison
people that desecrated the flag
yeah that was stupid insanity yeah so
but a lot a lot of conservatives agreed
with him
stupid virtue signaling if it's your
property and you want to burn it so long
as you burn it safely i got no problem
either virtue signaling or pure idiocy
yeah see that's that and that was one of
the that's like another
thing that i was really concerned about
with trump is just his approach to free
speech with
with his calls to repeal section 230
with his calls to uh to make it easier
to sue media companies
um right like what we were just talking
about i think that
well sewing media companies isn't a bad
thing it could be if
it could be more liable laws and stuff i
mean yeah that was definitely the stop
criticism of him i believe well the
issue is that
there's a really tough standard right
now from a ruling called times v
sullivan
where media outlets you have to prove
they knowingly lied
and it almost never even gets to the
point where you can right so there's
there's things called anti-slap laws
basically
the new york times could publish
whatever well here's a better example
the today show outright lied
they used clever language and how they
lied and if i did sue
they'd just be like get out of here but
i'm like if we went to discovery
if you allow this case i might find
their messages where they say
hey does this sound you know legit
because i know it's not true who knows
what they're saying behind the scenes
but you never even make it there so i
definitely think there's room to
solve some of these problems i actually
think the solution is if there's a
defamation
i should be able to sue for a correction
if i can prove
it was false that means even if you make
a mistake
i can say i would like you to correct
this if you say no i can sue you and the
relief from the court is
publish the correction if it's proven in
the court to be true but we don't even
have that right now so something has to
be done
yeah absolutely and you know i know
before we went live you were showing me
some examples of like media bias and
stuff and
i would never deny that the media is
incredibly biased
and it just i mean it would depend on
the publication also but i like your
idea with the defamation thing that
would yeah that makes a lot of sense
actually because it's weird right now
where
a news organization will publish
something false and then someone will
sue and say hey
or someone will complain it's false and
they'll say well we're not going to
correct it it's like
if come on like that's just dirty yeah
yeah it's
but you can't sue for that you should be
able to i don't know how you get to that
point or how a law is made
if you did would they have to pay for uh
court fees as well
yeah if you proved it to be false then
they should be responsible for the court
fees
because that means before you went to
court you attempted to resolve the
problem
so or i i should put it this way you
know if you don't attempt to resolve it
then maybe
no but if i contact you and say hey this
article is incorrect here's the proof
and you say f off
okay i'm going to sue you and when i win
you'll be responsible for court fees if
they say f
off well then it's their problem what
about damages no
okay uh if it's not intentional and you
can't prove it
that's that's the problem like if i say
something like you know ian crossland
was wearing a don't say it
wearing a blue sweater don't defame me
like that and i was just like
you know what i made a mistake because i
so the lights were off
the lights were off and it was an honest
mistake then
we we need that leeway for error yeah
otherwise news organizations couldn't
function
but we can allow them just be like i
lied and you can't do anything about it
that's where they're at right now
right yeah i mean i i definitely think
that like there's there's
room for conversation there but i think
that donald trump's calling to repeal
libel laws and the way he set it to so
we can make a bunch of money or whatever
i don't
i don't think that it was coming from a
sincere and nuanced perspective like
what you have
i think that it was coming from media
companies are criticizing me and i want
to be able to sue them easier
i mean i don't know you you talk to a
trump sport i'll tell you one thing you
talk someone hates trump they'll tell
you the other so as far as i
i can tell as i just assess it on the
merits is there a good reason to go
after these these you know the current
system absolutely it's kind of messed up
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time